you were saying before physical health
if you don't have physical health
nothing else matters as soon as you get
sick but how do you how do you how do
you get people to understand that
without
making them sick
i don't um i think there are certain
ways you can talk about it i don't think
that you can really understand it until
you've been sick especially mentally ill
i think it's very difficult to
understand mentally ill people unless
you've been there so
i think i've done an alright job
describing some of the experiences i've
had but only because i'm out of it now
and i think a lot of people who are that
sick
don't get out of it so
i don't know how you do i don't know how
you describe i i feel like your
solution kind of defies modern logic yes
so you're you're doing the carnivore
diet
and you just will you only eat lamb
yeah so i reach there's the carnivore
diet which is all animal products and
that's the one that you see in the news
like eggs milk anything that comes from
an animal carnivore diet i reframed mine
as the lion diet
which is insane but i did that i did
that
and that's
beef lamb or any type of room in an
animal so animals that have multiple
stomachs rumen oh really yeah
not any ungulate
what's that hoofed mammal
i feel like not any of them like horses
aren't yeah giraffes are goats yeah
giraffes are
yeah wow oh god i hope i'm right about
that i'm pretty sure giraffes are a room
in an animal
so you'll eat like beef and beef and
lamb
yes elk sometimes
nothing else
and salt and water and i reintroduced
tea recently
but you do alcohol
yeah and that just discredits my entire
diet they're like okay you're only
eating oh yeah sure so you have an
autoimmune disorder but you can you can
drink alcohol i think but uh it's
distilled so like vodka and bourbon
there's nothing in it it's distilled
like three times
um
most people probably don't know what
distillation is but it removes all the
grain so i don't have any autoimmune
problems from alcohol because i would
imagine like fruit breaks down into
alcohol in your system i think and it's
probably really really good for your
yeah but there's a whole bunch of things
in fruit that aren't it's not just like
pure alcohol right like vodka yeah
pre-pure where do you get your vitamin c
from
so there's a tiny bit of vitamin c in
meat a tiny bit and it turns out if
you're not eating any carbs glucose and
vitamin c compete so if you don't have
glucose you don't use as much vitamin c
so you don't need as much vitamin c but
i've been doing this since december 2017
and the vitamins i was deficient in when
i had an autoimmune disorder have
recovered
since when what year december 2017. it's
been a while yeah here you urinate a lot
of the vitamin c out and maybe that's
because the glucose is preventing it
from being absorbed
i have no idea but they do compete yeah
so possibly if that's what happens so so
let's start from the beginning i guess
you were you were sick
i was i'll give you the like super
tight version of it um i was diagnosed
with juvenile rheumatoid arthritis in 37
joints when i was seven
i was put on two immune suppressants in
an anti-inflammatory medication
um the immune suppressants i injected so
very serious immune suppressants when i
was in grade 6 i was diagnosed with
major depressive disorder or possibly
bipolar type 2 depending on the
physician and i was put on ssris
grade 8 i started to get chronically
fatigued so i was medicated with
adderall when i was 21 for idiopathic
hypersomnia so i used adderall just to
stay awake when i was 17 i had my hip
and ankle replaced from the arthritis
that wasn't kept in check properly with
the immune suppressants
yeah that's about it i was also
diagnosed with lyme disease eventually
and
i think that's all of them yeah so how
did how did you come to the carnivore
diet
um
oh i started getting this rash called
dermatitis herpetiformis which is an
itchy blistering rash and it's the skin
manifestation of celiac disease which is
the only autoimmune disorder associated
with gluten
so i figured okay maybe gluten maybe i
have celiac disease i got my genes
tested i have the gene for celiac
disease i was like i'll cut out gluten
just to see maybe that's causing my
arthritis and that kind of led me on
i must have read like 1500 1200 articles
on autoimmune disorders gluten link
possible dairy link and then i went back
to school for biomedical science to try
and research
my disorder because at that point i was
so sick i thought it was going to kill
me my skin had stopped healing from the
rash i'd had two joints replaced
my wrist felt like it was going to need
a replacement i couldn't wake up like so
i was like okay well this is what i'm
doing with my life because i don't have
a life so i started researching and then
i just decided to look into diet to see
if it had any
if it made any impact and at that time i
didn't think it would change anything
but i figured i'd rule it out and first
i went to paleo so like no grains no soy
no dairy no sugar only water no
processed foods
and then when i stopped taking ssris so
that worked that actually worked my
arthritis went away my fatigue went away
i got off of adderall
and my depression lifted and then when i
went off of vsaucerise i did that way
too rapidly because i didn't know they
cause withdrawal
and that's when i ended up on the meat
diet because i got sensitive to light
and to sound and to heat and to touch
and to any amount of carb i was reacting
to everything so that's when i went down
to beef
and lamb and salt and water which was
like out of desperation because the
anti-depressant withdrawal was so awful
when you first went on carnivore what
did you cut out
at that point i actually just went from
chicken and beef and fish
and lettuce
and green leafy vegetables
olive oil
and apple cider vinegar so i literally
just dropped salad at that point because
i didn't know you could survive on only
meat so i was like well i need some
greens i react the least amount to the
salad so i kept the salad for a long
time and then eventually i was like i
can't live like this anymore because i
was having some autoimmune symptoms i
was not on any medication at that point
i was trying to get it under control and
i was like i'll just do
just beef cause i know i don't react to
beef just for a very short period of
time so that i can reintroduce things
and monitor my symptoms and i was
keeping track of it on like excel
spreadsheets my symptoms and everything
and my symptoms went away when i went to
all beef
and
and then when i tried to reintroduce
they came back so i haven't been able to
reintroduce things i can have tea now
but that's like three years into the
diet and i introduced tea i didn't drink
for a long time because i was worried
alcohol was gonna be a problem obviously
did you go to a bunch of doctors and
they
no at that point honestly i'd been doing
paleo i when i went to the carnivore
diet i'd been dieting for two years
being more and more restrictive and a
year into dieting after i went off of my
ssris i'd been talking to immunologists
and and just nobody ever like my
rheumatologist didn't believe me like
nobody believed me i barely believed
myself so no at that point i was like
the medical community does not know how
to handle this do you know what breath
aryans are i do
yeah so uh do you know do you guys know
yeah let's go
these are people who
insist
they can subsist off of light and air
only get to them and there was one woman
this is a brutal video where she claimed
that she was a breatharian she only just
absorbed sunlight and breathed to
survive so they were like okay we're
gonna film you
for i think it was like five days to see
you know you
survive without eating food so you can
prove that you're not eating or drinking
and she agreed to do it and she was so
dead set on proving this by like day
three when her like heart levels were
through the roof she was mel she was she
was like getting sick she was dehydrated
they were like we have to stop now like
your your health is at serious risk
you're getting worse and so then she
said something like oh it's the air like
the air here is bad it's polluted we
have to go somewhere else and it didn't
change anything
so it's it's fascinating because you
hear stories like that as why people
probably don't believe you yeah well no
[ __ ] i wouldn't believe me either i
didn't even think no seriously like a
buzzfeed will come out with an article
and be like look at this person and i'll
be like yeah
i get it i get it i was like when i was
22 and people were like fix your diet
that'll fix your autoimmune disorder you
know eat healthier i was just like you
don't know what i'm going through you
don't know how serious this is like diet
cannot have an impact like that because
my joints
disappeared right like it's not diet i
didn't think being gluten-free was a
thing i thought that was a fad i was
scoffing at organic stores i went
completely in the other direction like i
had no i was shocked i probably i i
probably walked around with my mouth
open for the first year after i found
out the diet impacted my health because
i really didn't think what i ain't
mattered at all so i get it did you see
like gummy bears and stuff when you were
a kid
sour patch candy yes holy [ __ ] sour keys
i never had those kids you've never had
a sour key have you had sour patch candy
yeah they're like they're like worse
more stale larger versions of sour patch
dude sour patch kids oh my god so much
candy
when i first went to the paleo diet that
was my first food that i reintroduced
because i was like there's no soy
there's no dairy no one's allergic to
sugar
right it was like like a for a physical
reaction i was like sugar's not good but
no one's allergic to it like i want my
sour patch candy it did not go well i
just the vitamin c thing is what gets me
like i guess i could understand you know
they have uh like there's the keto diet
right
but it's keto isn't no carb it's just
low carb you get some carbs you have way
more variety than what i'm doing oh
absolutely but then there's um what is
it called gluconeogenesis yeah where you
the protein the protein is converted
into sugars for your brain and stuff
like that yeah so you still have a
stable blood sugar like my blood sugar
is usually at i don't know what it's in
i don't know what it's in it's usually
at around 80 though which is pretty good
it's not like 50 is pretty low 80 is
pretty good 130 that's high and then
people go way up from there but mine's
at 80 stably so yeah gluconeogenesis
from protein yeah but the vitamin c
thing is what gets me
yeah yeah
yeah yeah well i don't think people
really know like um part of the reason
i'm talking about it is because
i would like the medical community to
take it seriously enough to do some case
studies to look into it because i've
seen it help a lot of people and it
sounds unbelievable
the the keto diet for i think it's it's
prescribed by doctors for people with
epilepsy since the 20s yeah it kind of
lost favor because anti-epileptics came
out and people stopped using the diet
because it was hard to adhere to but
yeah they've been using the keto diet
for a long time and technically this is
a keto diet technically if you wanted to
refer to it it's like a plant-free keto
diet but keto is way more fat than that
i was eating a lot of fat initially i
because i thought ketosis was part of
the reason it was helping so it was like
add on the fat and at that point i was
still having ssri withdrawal so i had a
lot of neurological symptoms and the fat
kind of i felt like i needed it uh for
about two years i was maybe eighty
percent of my calories were from fat so
i was i was yeah i was
in like high level of ketogenesis but i
don't do that anymore we've got a ton of
food here we've got snacks over there
with milk duds and skittles or whatever
no we don't actually we do have skittles
and sodas and you know like we have
these these meals sometimes when guests
come they'll like we have these like
easy prep meals but you actually had
like a little rack of lamb or something
oh yeah i full on yeah you guys drove me
um
you guys drove me
to the grocery store yeah and i bought a
rack of lamb and then i cooked it yeah
it's legit in the oven yeah it tasted
really good too i ate part of it yeah
yeah did you do like lifestyle changes
in addition to diet
not uh not initially so at first it was
just diet because i'm not like i'm not
one of those i mean i'm getting more
into it now but i was never one of those
lifestyle like biohacker people i was
really into neurotropics first i was
really into drugs and i was like how do
i drug myself better so i had this like
tylenol three at night gravel at night
adderall to keep me awake like i was on
like seven different drugs and i
actually drugged myself enough
that
i could think clearly enough that i
figured it out and got off of all the
drugs so it actually worked out for you
yeah but i started there then i went to
neurotropics then i went to diet
um and then i started like when i got a
little bit healthier i was like oh okay
managing my sleep actually does help me
uh saunas infrared saunas were a game
changer really from my mood no we don't
have an infrastructure
infrared because they don't heat up too
much you can stay in there for a long
time and just sweat that helped me so
much when i was trying to reintroduce
food and having autoimmune reactions uh
infrared saunas absolutely absolute game
changer and now i do like wim hof
breathing ice baths like i've gone full
swing i've got my aura ring but
initially
this yeah i don't know but it has three
little sensors to monitor your
heart rate oh yeah i want to get one of
those they're actually kind of cool yeah
they make you really neurotic about how
you sleep i got the watch which is not
the same but it like tracks
steps it tracks calories burned workout
time and movement per hour
what kind of watch is that it's the
galaxy something or other
android galaxy samsung yeah samsung yeah
yeah so i get um uh every day it gives
me like a little man like every hour if
i if i'm sitting down working on the
computer it tells you to stand like the
apple the apple watch does that right a
little man will appear and he'll like
start doing like deep knee bends or back
you do not get moving i don't do deep
knee bench but i'll get up and i'll go
walk around i'll be like i shouldn't
just be sitting here non-stop staring at
a screen so i'll go outside i'll go
check on the chickens take five like a
five minute break and then go back and
then it's like good job and at the end
of the day nice because because i skate
every day so i'm getting exercise uh i
get i get the eight hours of sleep well
i don't think i don't think i sleep for
eight hours but i sleep enough when i
move enough that it gives me little
little hearts and then it shows you your
your days and you get like a little it's
a foot with like a badge it's like you
did it and if you don't what if you
don't do it yeah then you don't get your
little [ __ ] okay so it's not that harsh
depending on how badly you can take
criticism yeah it should i i think we
should actually make an app where it's
like you're a loser like a little guy
what are you doing with your life my dad
could pop up yeah yeah yeah yourself did
you grow up with this thing you can find
and carry it yeah did he just like
constantly like organize you into this
lifestyle your entire life not not
really i think one thing he did that was
super beneficial was he said as soon as
i got diagnosed with juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis when i was in grade two i
remember he sat me down and he said you
can never use your illness as an excuse
good for him wow yeah and it was like
which is a serious thing to tell a kid
who has three arthritis and 37 joints
but it was basically like this is gonna
suck no matter what but if you use it as
an excuse it's gonna suck more yeah and
so that was i think that was really
beneficial to me and i probably veered
in the direction of never using it as an
excuse when i probably should have spent
a couple days in bed but
i don't have an autoimmune disorder but
let's let's
let's talk about this i think one of the
biggest problems we have right now as a
society is everyone using all of that as
an excuse
yeah i know it's exhausting right it's
it's i'm a victim for this reason that
reason or otherwise they're told that
though and part of the problem i have
with the medical community is when you
go in and you get diagnosed when i got
diagnosed
uh my mom because she's been she's like
the hippie of the family and she was
like can we just change diet and they're
just like hahaha they literally just
laughed um which is fair because dietary
changes are complicated for autoimmune
disorders
but
i don't know where i was going with that
what are we just talking about how
people are using their their their bad
lifestyles excuses for why they can't
succeed or yeah okay part of the problem
with medical yeah community is when
you're when you go in there you're
diagnosed they tell you
your only hope is us your only hope are
these medications and there's nothing
you can do about it and it's not your
fault and so it takes all the
responsibility away from yourself for
fixing it because you're like i can't
the authority figures that know what
they're doing they went to school told
me that i can't and i think if i had
just if they'd just been like
can't help good luck then i would be
like oh [ __ ] i have to figure this out
myself and i would have gone through all
these paths like diet exercise i just
would have looked um but i think yeah
the schooling system is doing the same
thing to people people are told you know
you have this mental illness it's on you
don't worry it's not your fault like
here's a medication or
or you're an outsider
so you deserve deserve some sort of
i don't know help for being an outsider
just yeah society right now is pathetic
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time